the Senate will formally set the stage
today for its impeachment trial of
President Trump it's the first ever of a
president running in an election year
House leaders delivered the articles of
impeachment yesterday investigators
released more evidence from a man
involved in the operation that triggered
this whole impeachment inquiry that man
is led partes he worked for the
president's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani and was a central figure in the
scheme to pressure Ukraine to
investigate former Vice President Joe
Biden and his son in explosive
interviews yesterday partes linked the
president and other administration
officials to the effort including the
Vice President Attorney General and the
national security advisor at the time
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill force
Nancy good morning so the big question
is credibility what do we know about
Parnas well Parnas claims that he was
the man on the ground for Rudy Giuliani
and the President himself tasked with
making sure that Ukraine opened an
investigation into the Biden's Democrats
concede that Parnas has some credibility
issues he was recently charged with
federal campaign finance violations but
Parnas says that in no uncertain terms
that the president and even the vice
president knew what he was up to and
that there's more evidence to come
President Trump know exactly what was
going on he was aware of my movements he
I wouldn't do anything without the
consent of Rudy Giuliani or the
president Rudy Giuliani's former
associate Lev Parnas insists he was
working on president Trump's behalf when
he pressured Ukrainian leaders it was
never about corruption it was never it
was strictly about the barista mob which
included hunter Biden and Joe Biden
president Trump has denied even knowing
Parnas he lied let me mean and then
watch football games together with in
heat hot dogs but he knew exactly who we
were harness says that while he was
pushing for an investigation into the
Biden's his connection to the president
was made clear to the Ukrainians we
party on the farm Rudy relate to him
basically that we were there on behalf
of the
president the United States in a
statement to MSNBC Giuliani denied doing
that harness says his connection to the
White House was evident when the vice
president canceled his trip to president
solinsky's May 20th inauguration harness
had warned the Ukrainians that no US
official would attend the inauguration
without the Biden investigation
announced now they realized that without
what I was telling mr. Parnas an
indicted businessman says a host of top
officials knew about the Ukraine
pressure campaign including former
national security adviser John Bolton
you believe he knows what the
administration was pressuring Ukraine to
do 100 percent and Attorney General
William bar bar was Attorney General
Barr was basically the team a Justice
Department spokeswoman says that is a
hundred percent false
Parnas has handed over a trove of
documents to house investigators
including text messages voicemails and
pictures of him with members of the
Trump family Democrats say the evidence
bolsters their case that the Senate
trial should include new witnesses and
documents I don't know how any member of
this body could pick up the newspaper
this morning read this new revelation
and not conclude that the Senate needs
access to relevant documents like these
in the trial of President Trump today
the seven house managers who will
essentially serve as the prosecutors in
this Senate trial are going to walk the
articles of impeachment to the Senate
where they will read the articles aloud
on the Senate floor Chief Justice John
Roberts will be sworn in and he will in
turn swear in the 100 senators who are
going to serve as jurors when the trial
begins next week senators will have to
sit quietly they can only listen they
can't talk to one another can't even
bring in any reading material scale that
don't pertain to the trial boy Nancy
people's heads were spinning in
Washington yesterday but let's go back
to parties for a second I felt like I
needed to have a little teacup with my
pinkie finger out he was
feeling so much tea as the kids of today
say so what are we hearing about these
new details from what he said and how
that could affect the Senate trial well
it's a real bombshell Gale because he's
the first individual to say point-blank
that he was working to pressure the
Ukrainians on behalf of the President
and with his knowledge others have
couched it they've said that this was
their understanding that this is what
the president wanted or that they heard
it secondhand some Senate Republicans
however are questioning the timing of
all this they want to know why it wasn't
included in the house impeachment
investigation and that might lead some
of them to argue that they shouldn't
consider it when they're sitting
listening to this trial trying to decide
whether the president should be kept in
office you know a lot to sort out there
thank you very much Nancy
you